été 2021 nothing arrive la marque No
sing arrive avec des anciens membres de
oneplus qui viennent créer cet énorme
boîte petite boîte start-up mais qui
devient énorme de plus en plus énorme
ils arrivent avec de tout premiers
écouteurs ce sont les nothing one que je
vous avais bien évidemment présenté le
design est complètement nouveau on
repart sur un design plutôt année 70 un
truc très transparent esprit un peu
plastique bon truc est plutôt sympa
j'aime beaucoup ils arrivent ensuite
l'année dernière je sais pas si c'est le
mois de juin je peux vous dire de
bêtises je crois que c'est je vois
peut-être juillet 2022 avec un téléphone
on se parle de ce téléphone là c'est le
nothing phone one premier téléphone de
la marque plutôt intéressant design très
différent avec surtout la glift
interface avec un design très à pas avec
des sons avec de la lumière avec de
l'image nos signes a continué son
histoire avec des sticks qui sont juste
là dedans à l'intérieur sont les IR
stick plutôt aussi sympathique l'aspect
plutôt sympa bon ok ça continue à
évoluer donc vous voyez on a déjà deux
produits audio et là aussi revient
encore avec un nouveau produit audio qui
est en fait une la solution des Iran
avec les nothing to qui arrivent dans
cette boîte là alors qu'ils sont déjà
ici là dans ma main vous voyez parce que
les nothing Virtu je m'amuse avec je les
aux oreilles je les écoute et je dois
vous donner mon retour dans quelques
instants donc on se regarde aujourd'hui
ce que raconte ces notions quels sont
les nouveautés par rapport aux anciens
est-ce qu'ils sont intéressants est-ce
qu'il faut venir les acheter pour qu'ils
sont faits si vous avez un smartphone un
iPhone ou si vous avez un smartphone
Android et bien est-ce qu'il fonctionne
dans les deux cas au-delà d'avoir bien
évidemment un aussi une phone c'est la
question laquelle on va répondre quel
est le tarif réduction de bruit par
réduction de bruit qualité audio bref il
y a plein de choses à venir raconter sur
ces écouteurs au-delà du design qui est
quand même très sympa donc est-ce que
vous êtes prêt je suis hyper chaud hyper
chaud allez on y va c'est parti
[Musique]
alors on y va avant toute chose avant
même de vous montrer ces écouteurs et
avant de vous raconter et vous dire tout
ce que j'en pense je veux qu'on retourne
un peu derrière pour vous montrer
l'expérience unboxing parce qu'ici on se
parle bien d'une expérience avec Grèce
unique c'est rigolo alors on y va
retourner dans le passé on remonte un
peu dans le passé ça c'était bien avant
de commencer à tester ce produit et bien
je vais vous montrer l'unboxing parce
que c'est toujours un truc qui est très
particulier chez nosting c'est à dire
que vous avez des boîtes à usage unique
il y a plein de marques où vous ouvrez
votre boîte pour leur fermer la
retrouver l'utiliser là vous avez cette
petite languette ça veut dire que
lorsque vous avez commencé à tirer sur
la languette et bien il est plus
possible de retrouver sa boîte comme
elle était avant alors on peut la voir
mais elle va être un peu abîmée parce
que c'est comme une languette sur les
flambies une fois que vous l'avez
démoulé mais vous le remettez pas dedans
bon vous allez comprendre un peu
l'histoire ce qui donne une expérience
unique vous l'unboxez une fois et c'est
tout alors la boîte en elle-même elle
est très jolie design elle reprend
vraiment ses codes de nos signes c'est
du nothing fait pour nos signes bien
évidemment c'est joli c'est sympa avec
cette typo qu'on va retrouver vraiment à
l'arrière voyez même ici la façon dont
ils viennent vous écrire toutes les
informations sur le produit et bien
c'est assez typé c'est très joli et puis
pour l'ouvrir vous venez vous prenez la
petite languette qui est juste là elle
vient et vous avez plus qu'à un merde je
suis foiré le truc ça s'est pété là
enfin quand même c'est dommage j'ai pété
l'expérience oh non ça fait tellement
bien marché sur tous les autres produits
de l'insigne que j'ai eu que la non ah
c'est con merde bon ciseaux on reprend
l'histoire on va voir si on peut
continuer quand même malgré tout donc
normalement vous prenez vous ouvrez tout
comme ça si je me fais pas une main ou
un doigt je suis bien content on va
prendre ça ça ira très bien regardez
normalement vous avez les languettes qui
va jusqu'au bout vous voyez qui est là
là vous voyez c'est ça qui aurait dû
venir et qui est pas venu bon dommage
donc vous retrouver à l'intérieur d'un
petit Q pour venir scanner et retrouver
directement l'application nothing une
fois de plus c'est plutôt bien fait
plutôt joli petit guide ici avec je
pense les informations essentielles une
fois de plus le QR code les infos la
lumière les boutons le charging port ça
vous explique comment ça marche ok on va
s'en sortir on a ensuite ici à
l'intérieur les écouteurs en eux-mêmes
se trouve un peu plus compact à la boîte
plutôt sympa aussi une fois de plus il
garde vraiment le même aspect esthétique
avec ce côté très transparent qui
viennent typer ce produit que je trouve
vraiment très très joli donc là vous
pouvez poser votre doigt et venir le
faire tourner comme ça si vous êtes
spécialiste pour faire un tour des trucs
comme ça vous pouvez venir le faire vous
voyez ça c'est marrant bon ok il y a un
côté un peu gadget mais moi ça me fait
bien barrer donc ok pourquoi pas ensuite
je viens les ouvrir comme ça je vois
bien que effectivement j'ai une petite
lettre qui vient situer juste là mes
écouteurs je pose aux oreilles
directement ça se fait parfaitement
parfaitement fit et alors ça se met très
très facilement ça dépend des oreilles
il y a des gens chez qui ça va être plus
compliqué moi je pose hop je tourne je
suis directement dedans deuxième oreille
je prends hop je pose je tourne pareil
directement dedans réduction déjà de
bruit passifs comme ça ce que je
constate c'est que ça ne bouge plutôt
bien les oreilles c'est efficace ok ça
marche ensuite vous le voyez ici vous
avez vos petits connecteurs là pour
venir les recharger d'un côté l'autre
donc vous venez vous le reposer hop vous
avez le code couleur aussi là qui vous
indique bien quel écouteur c'est donc là
j'ai le rouge le rouge le rouge dans le
rouge ça va bien le blanc dans le blanc
hop PAF tac comme ça ça va bien ça fit
ensuite qu'est-ce que j'ai là j'ai mon
petit bouton ici ok j'ai mon USB C pour
venir le recharger puis ça fait pour
tout et après à l'intérieur de la boîte
je vais retrouver mes autres tailles
alors regardez vous le marque bien là
taille S et L que vous allez pouvoir
venir retrouver ici pour venir adapter à
la taille des oreilles de chacun on a
pas tous ces mêmes tailles d'oreilles
donc ça c'est plutôt cool donc là vous
les avez ici et ensuite de l'autre côté
je pense que je vais voir mon câble avec
l'USB C exactement et même le câble est
joli ça y est on reste vraiment dans
l'idée de ce qu'ils aiment faire de ce
qu'ils savent faire donc voilà voilà
pour ce unboxing assez rapide
personnellement c'est efficace on se
retrouve après un claquement de doigts
pour la partie tasse vous êtes prêt ok
nous voilà on est de retour alors
regardez regardez-moi c'est nothing Hir
to on reprend la même formule qui avait
très bien fonctionné avec les héroïnes
alors les héros n'avaient bien
fonctionné parce qu'il y a vraiment un
côté novateur un design un peu différent
et ça changeait par rapport au marché
est-ce que on a les fait novateur est-ce
qu'on a fait waouh ici non parce que
quelque chose qu'on a déjà vu mais qui
pour le coup continue à bien fonctionner
à savoir que vous avez effectivement
cette coque qui est totalement
transparente que vous pouvez venir
ouvrir comme ça plutôt bien fichu avec
hop là vos écouteurs d'un côté et de
l'autre et les écouteurs en eux-mêmes
aussi garde ce côté transparent alors le
design il est quand même très sympa une
fois de plus on l'a déjà vu avec les
Erwan mais les touches je trouve aussi
une fois de plus très très très très
jolie parce que on a vraiment un design
très atypique quelque chose de très très
particulier ils tiennent vachement bien
dans les oreilles donc ça je vous les
montrer lors de l'unboxing on a déjà une
très bonne réduction de bruit passive
comme ça donc ça c'est très très bien et
surtout le truc qu'ils ont fait qui est
vraiment différent c'est à dire qu'avant
sur les Iran vous venez presser ici pour
pouvoir modifier vos commandes play
pause et si et ça alors là ils ont
vraiment changé l'histoire parce qu'ils
sont rendus compte que c'était peut-être
pas ce mieux vous venez vous poser vos
doigts et vous pressez tac et vous
sentez vraiment le clic vous entendez
vraiment donc là je viens d'en mettre de
la musique j'aurais pu une fois à ses
poses en fait c'est vous appuyez une
fois play une fois pose deux fois
morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent revient en morceaux d'avant ça
recommence mais du jazz ça vous savez
tout hop là je vais éteindre et lorsque
vous faites un appui long comme ça vous
laissez appuyer là ça me fait un le son
comme ça et bien en fait ça ça veut dire
que on ouvre en fait c'est vraiment le
côté sensation faut vraiment venir
l'écouter pour se rendre compte donc
lorsque vous faites ça c'est très
intuitif on comprend en fait ce qui se
passe on comprend tout à fait qu'on
vient de désactiver la réduction de
bruit active j'ouvre et on entend ce qui
se passe autour de nous lorsque je
rappuie un contrario pour fermer ça fait
comme ça ça sent vraiment comme un
bouchon qui viendrait se poser sur une
bouteille et là la réduction de bruit
active est activée donc fatalement je
vous entends quand même un peu moins
bien voilà je fais comme ça et voilà et
là ça ouvre davantage voilà un peu pour
ces comment tactiles qui ont ils sont
vraiment venus changer et qui sont
intéressantes ici au niveau de ses
écouteurs au niveau ensuite de la caisse
de la coque de l'étude protection c'est
plus alterne il y a pas grand chose de
nouveau hein ça fonctionne exactement
les manières c'est très simple c'est
sympa c'est joli vous venez mettre vos
écouteurs dedans alors après il y a un
truc à savoir c'est que vos écouteurs
ils sont certifiés les écouteurs
l'intention bien que les écouteurs IP 54
c'est à dire qu'ils sont résistants à
l'eau et à la poussière à la
transpiration on va pas aller se baigner
dans une piscine avec et votre étui a
également une certification lui c'est
une certification
IP55 c'est la même chose ça peut même
principe si il pleut un petit peu il y a
des petits gouttes d'eau ça va aller une
fois de plus vous le mettez pas en
contact avec de la flotte vous jetez pas
dans de la flotte pour éviter les
déconvenue donc le confort je vous ai
dit le confort est bien l'étui est sympa
il passe très bien dans une poche il est
sympa il est différent le design est top
je continue vraiment aimer ce design
sauf que no sing c'est vraiment une
marque qui pour le coup prend des
risques et veut être différent dans
l'industrie alors ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur c'est un peu la même façon
qu'on peut retrouver ailleurs mais d'un
point de vue purement esthétique c'est
vraiment différent alors moi je veux
qu'on parle un petit peu de l'intérieur
parce que c'est le sujet qui nous
intéresse ici vous allez avoir un driver
de
16,6 mm on nous annonce ici du graphène
un petit peu plus léger là vous voyez
pour vous écouteurs vous les sentiez pas
alors je vous parlais du confort mais en
termes de sensation personnellement
lorsque je viens parler comme ça
regardez là vous voyez hop là et ben ça
va ça pas il bouge pas ils sont très
bien calés dans ma tête j'ai la bonne
taille une fois de plus ça dépend parce
que tout le monde n'a pas des oreilles
pour accepter ça enfin tout à des
oreilles moi j'espère que vous avez des
oreilles en tout cas on a pas tous la
même forme d'oreille donc ça conviendra
pas nécessairement à tout le monde mais
si vous craignez pas les bugs et que ça
rentre dans vos oreilles c'est plutôt
bien on n'est pas sur des choses qui
viennent se poser c'est vraiment sur des
intrasses ça rentre à l'intérieur vous
lui mettre un petit coup de visse là hop
là tac c'est fermé c'est poser et là ça
bouge absolument pas donc ça c'est très
très bien donc une fois de plus lorsque
vous venez parler on a vraiment un bon
confort on a vraiment une bonne tenue
donc ça ça marche vraiment bien petite
astuce si vous voulez profiter des
meilleurs masses pensez vraiment à bien
les visser bien les positionner à
l'intérieur ça viendra faire un peu plus
caisse de résonance et ça sera bien
mieux en termes d'expérience audio donc
ils sont hyper confort ils se
maintiennent très très bien donc ça
c'est vraiment un truc très cool le
design est léger ça se positionne super
bien on trouve très facilement l'accès
aux petits boutons vous voyez que le
côté je pense et on entend plus rien
j'ai vraiment un petit clic j'entends le
bouton mécanique j'entends vraiment
l'action mécanique dans mes oreilles
alors après chez nocine ils ont dû faire
leur petite sauce en interne pour venir
améliorer la qualité audio et pour ça
que ça fonctionne mieux et surtout ils
sont dû rajouter des codes alors en plus
du a assez et du SB vous avez à
l'intérieur je mets mes trucs n'importe
comment je fais n'importe quoi faut me
le dire vous avez du lhdc 5.0 donc ok ça
fonctionnera pas de souci là-dessus ils
nous ont mis en place une autre
technologie pour améliorer la qualité du
son lors de vos appels téléphoniques
c'est la clear Voice technologique qui
marche très bien pas de souci au niveau
des appels on les appelle de bonne
qualité donc là-dessus ok une fois de
plus je voudrais qu'on se parle
maintenant de la réduction de bruit
parce que c'est une promesse qui est
faite c'est une des specs qui est là
c'est de venir vous enfermer un petit
peu et vous coupez du bruit extérieur
alors nothing est venu travailler sur sa
réduction de bruit pour l'améliorer bien
évidemment par rapport à la génération
précédente vos écouteurs vont être
capables de reconnaître le son
environnant pour venir s'adapter de
façon dynamique par rapport au bruit que
vous allez avoir à l'extérieur si par
exemple vous vous mettez sur une
réduction de bruit dans un jardin et
bien vous allez pas avoir le même
problématique que dans un train dans un
métro dans un avion bien évidemment donc
lui il va venir s'adapter pour optimiser
un peu l'expérience alors moi la
réduction de bruit ça se trouve pas mal
attention les écouteurs on est à 149
euros on est un petit peu moins de 150
balles 149 euros on va pas s'attendre à
avoir une réduction de bruit comme sur
des écouteurs à 250 balles 300 balles je
trouve néanmoins qu'à 149 euros le job
est fait le job est fait correctement on
va pas avoir la même chose que sur les
derniers écouteurs intra de Bose où on a
une réduction de bruit qui est une
qualité supérieure mais à un tarif
largement aussi supérieur donc là je
dirais que pour 150 balles vous en avez
pour votre argent et ça fonctionne bien
alors je vous montrerai après parce que
une application qui est vachement cool
c'est nothing X vous pouvez venir
utiliser pour utiliser vos écouteurs
pour dire personnaliser l'expérience ça
c'est cool mais au-delà de ça qu'on se
parle un petit peu maintenant de la
qualité audio parce que si on achète des
écouteurs alors c'est bien évidemment
pour venir se la péter avec ça parce que
c'est joli mais ce qu'on veut en plus
c'est profiter d'une bonne expérience
audio et ici on a un truc qui est pas
mal attention on est une fan de plus à
149 euros donc c'est toujours un peu
compliqué à venir le mettre en
perspective par rapport à les écouteurs
qui seraient beaucoup plus cher et par
rapport à des moins chers fatalement il
sera mieux donc bon tout ça pour vous
dire que moi je trouve que la qualité
audio n'est pas mauvaise elle est pas
mal mais je vais lui reprocher par
moment peut-être d'un tout petit peu de
brillance dans les aigus je trouve que
au niveau des médiums vous avez
globalement ce qu'il faut j'ai écouté
plein de musique différents styles du
jazz du rock j'écoutais du métal j'ai
écouté plein un truc et je suis toujours
un peu le même reproche c'est à dire de
trouver que il manque très légèrement de
brillance j'ai des basses elles sont
présentes c'est pas les bases c'est plus
profondes et ça fait le table dans vos
écouteurs il y a pas de souci vous avez
vraiment ce qu'il faut après vous allez
voir vous avez un équaliseur à
l'intérieur pour venir un petit peu
optimiser l'histoire mais il a aussi ses
limites et je vous le montre dans
quelques instants mais déjà ces
écouteurs comme ils sont là l'expérience
audio est correcte vous en avez pour
votre argent vous en avez pour 149 €
chaque mois j'ai l'habitude d'écouter
énormément d'écouteurs différents et
énormément de casques différents et je
suis habitué à avoir beaucoup de
brillance dans mes écouteurs et ici ça
m'a légèrement frustré de pas la
retrouver énormément mais une fois de
plus j'en mets tout ça en perspective
par rapport au tarif sans 49 euros donc
les médiums sont présents les médiums
sont beaux je manque un peu de brillance
je peux venir corriger vous montrer
comment ça corriger un peu l'histoire et
sinon globalement ça fonctionne je vais
pas avoir de fréquence parasite j'ai pas
avoir de ce qui va être relou et qui va
être moche dans les oreilles je vais
avoir un poil trop de médium qu'on peut
venir légèrement casser si on le
souhaite dans l'application d'ailleurs
parce que l'application et je vous en
parle bah regardez on va dire jeter un
coup d'œil ensemble dessus votre
application se trouve dans votre
smartphone ou dans votre Smartphone vous
venez et vous allez chercher nothing X
juste ici donc vous cliquez dessus donc
là vous arrivez sur votre application je
vois plusieurs choses déjà ça met mon
niveau de batterie sur le haut juste ici
ça me le marque également ici j'ai aussi
mon niveau de batterie de mon étui je
vais avoir mon raccourci vers
l'équaliseur vers les commandes et vers
le contrôle de brouilles alors regardez
si je veux aller sur mon équaliseur
alors ils ont fabriqué un système au
niveau de l'équaliseur je suis pas super
super fan parce que et je vous explique
une fois de plus le bouzin ici en fait
ils vous ont fait un système à trois
niveaux vous pouvez venir personnaliser
c'est à dire de base vous avez soit
équilibré plus de graves plus d'aigu et
la voix et vous voyez ça vient moduler
directement ici équilibré vous avez le
même son un peu partout plus de grave
vous en douterez ça va être un varier un
peu plus sur les graves les aigus les
aigus la voix les médium en gros on l'a
compris soit on est sur un truc très
neutre soit plus de graves plus
d'aiguille ou plus de médium soit vous
venez vous le personnaliser et c'est là
où le bât blesse légèrement moi très
honnêtement je vous recommande équilibré
les autres je suis pas extrêmement fan
peut-être un peu plus de grave si vous
voulez un truc qui envoie un peu plus de
bois sur je vais penser peut-être du
hip-hop certains hip-hop ou sur je
dirais un peu de métal ou de l'électro
si on veut vraiment que ça devienne
gratter derrière sinon le personnalisé
il y a un truc qui me gêne un peu alors
je vous explique pourquoi parce qu'en
fait moi je me suis dit tiens si je me
remets par exemple vous voyez hopline et
quand je suis dessus si bien parce que
ça me le met en fait en grand comme ça
vu que mon doigt le cache je sais au
premier je suis au niveau de mes
aiguilles donc moi je me suis dit tiens
je vois un peu plus de grave et lorsque
je me montre mes graves là vous voyez je
vais pousser mes graves pas les mettre
trois fonds mais je mets à niveau 4 et
bien en fait ça fait un truc qui est un
peu con c'est à dire que au lieu de
venir uniquement monter mes graves et
conserver mesdames et mes aigus et bien
ça vient bouffer les fréquences au
niveau des médiums et des aigus et ça me
booste en fait les graves ça c'est une
certitude donc ça me mange du son au
niveau des médiums et des aigus donc en
fait en pensant monter du grave je viens
dégrader la qualité de mon signal sonore
donc je peux venir moduler mais très
légèrement tout en sachant que c'est la
même heure après je peux me dire ah bah
mince alors j'ai perdu des médias mais
des aigus donc je peux venir les
remonter mais si je remonte mes médiums
et mes aiguës dans les mêmes proportions
et bien arrivera un moment où j'aurai
exactement la même sensation sur
exactement la même recette donc ça ne
servira à rien donc en fait ce que j'ai
fait moi l'équilibre qui me semble être
le meilleur c'est de à zéro partout au
niveau des graves et au niveau des
médiums et je viens de mettre uniquement
mes aigus à plus ou plus de pas plus
sans me rajouter un petit peu plus de de
finesse vous voyez sur des cymbales sur
des soins un petit peu aiguës ça
m'emmène un peu plus d'air ça aère un
petit peu mon son donc voilà ce que je
viens faire moi mais au-delà de ça je
vais pas moduler davantage parce que ça
me bouffe un peu le son et c'est pas les
meilleurs équaliseurs qui existent sur
le marché par contre ils ont fait un
truc qui est très très bien chez nos
signes c'est que vous avez vraiment un
test d'audition pour adapter le son par
rapport à vous et à vos oreilles on a
tous des oreilles pas de plus j'espère
qu'on a tous des oreilles mais même si
vous avez pas d'oreilles c'est pas grave
mais en tout cas on peut venir
personnaliser l'expérience par rapport à
son audition moi je sais que j'ai une
petite pertes à gauche dans les médiums
que j'ai pas à droite donc je fais un
petit test qui est un peu con fait qui
me permet effectivement de venir
personnaliser mon profil donc je peux
refaire le test vous voyez là j'ai mon
profil et ça marque ce que ça va pouvoir
venir m'améliorer en termes de fréquence
par rapport à mon dernier test donc ça
c'est plutôt bien alors après je peux
venir mettre l'intensité plus ou moins
d'intensité et après je peux avoir soit
en recommandé soit plus doux plus étoffé
je peux vraiment dire choisir pour avoir
une expérience au nord personnalisée et
ça ça fonctionne bien donc ça ça me
plaît et ça c'est donc ça c'est cool
aucun problème là-dessus alors après
vous ont mis des petits informations au
niveau des commandes vous cliquez là
appuyez deux fois pour venir le moduler
alors avance rapide on trouve rapide
assistant vocal on peut venir mettre
l'assistant vocal on peut venir un peu
customiser pour avoir effectivement
appuyé deux fois appuyer trois fois à
gauche à droite comme ça on peut venir
totalement personnaliser l'expérience et
ça une fois de plus c'est quand même
vachement cool et là si vous revenez
dans vos veuillez appuie longuement
notamment sur la gauche et bien vous
voyez que vous avez le mode transparent
ça se fait sur le bruit ou alors même
carrément désactivé désactivez ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est de la
suppression de bruit passive donc vous
pouvez venir choisir entre un des trois
modes alors je vous le dis tout de suite
le mode transparent si vous injecte pas
énormément de son de l'extérieur c'est
pas le truc le plus fou du monde donc
moi ce que je vous recommande si vous
voulez être un petit peu aguerri et
savoir si ça se passe autour de vous et
bien vous enlevez vos écouteurs comme ça
ça évite les problèmes vous voyez mais
bon on peut venir en tout cas le mettre
ici et une fois de plus dire
personnalisé à droite et à gauche donc
cette expérience de personnalisation je
la trouve très maligne et très très bien
faite et le seul truc qui est non
personnalisable c'est appuyer une fois
voyez il est là il est non
personnalisable et puis une fois par
contre le fois trois fois l'appuyer
longuement appuyer deux fois et
maintenir on peut même venir faire et
bien je peux me dire choisir j'appuie
deux fois tac tac et je maintiens gros
c'est comme un trois clics avec le
troisième clic longtemps et bien vous
voyez ça me permet aussi de rajouter des
choses donc cette expérience là d'un
point de vue purement personnalisation
c'est le mot que je cherchais je la
trouve vachement bien donc ça c'est ça
très très bon point et puis après vous
avez le contrôle du bruit alors mode
transparence vous désactivez suppression
de bruit puis suppression personnalisée
du bruit la suppression du bruit est
calibrée en fonction de la sensibilité
auditive propre à chacun ça aussi c'est
pas mal donc une fois de plus on va dans
l'idée de la personnalisation et de la
customisation et je trouve que là-dessus
nos signes racontent une histoire qui
est assez jolie donc vous voyez ils sont
vraiment venus bosser la partie logiciel
alors après vous pouvez venir voir je
peux venir changer entre mes here tout
meilleur one si j'en veux au meilleur
stick à vous de voir et après j'ai plein
de petites options pour venir
gratouiller ici détection
intra-auriculaire suppression
personnalisée du bruit mode faible
latence audio de haute qualité vous
souhaitez sur votre codec lhdc j'ai pas
essayé sur l'application Apple
probablement qu'il n'y ait pas de toute
façon parce que c'est pas possible vous
avez pas de lhdc ici double connexion
donc là vous voyez hop faut un petit
redémarrer parce que oui effectivement
vous avez essayé du Bluetooth 5.3 pouvez
venir paramétrer pour avoir directement
vos écouteurs branchés sur votre
smartphone mais également sur votre
ordinateur si vous avez besoin la mise à
jour du firmware bien évidemment trouver
mes écouteurs bref il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'options alors tout ce que je
vais venir peut-être un petit peu
reprocher si je veux vraiment être un
peu de rechercher la petite bête c'est
que je trouve qu'il y a pas une énorme
différence de visibilité entre activée
et désactiver vous voyez ici je
désactive j'active ça se voit un peu sur
la droite mais c'est à peine un peu plus
clair ici pas énormément donc voyez
c'est du point de détail tout en sachant
que ici vous avez la détection lorsque
vous les mettez dans les oreilles et oui
un petit capteur qui vous dit ok sont
dans les oreilles ils sont connectés
directement ça c'est très pratique vous
avez en plus le Google fast paire pour
venir se connecter très facilement à
votre smartphone Android et vous avez le
Microsoft Swift pair pour venir le
connecter aussi très rapidement à votre
PC Microsoft et son plus venus
travailler au niveau de l'architecture
interne pour vous n'ayez pas de perte de
connexion en fait ils sont venus
améliorer les antennes à l'intérieur
donc c'est vrai que ça fonctionne bien
j'ai pas eu de perte de signal
globalement je suis très content en fait
une espèce de petite musique avec de la
qui est cool ça va me donner envie de
pisser dans 2 minutes l'autonomie aussi
est plutôt cool 36 heures sans réduction
de bruit active en gros vous avez deux
heures de plus par rapport à la
génération précédente tout en sachant
qu'en venant les charger ici pendant 10
minutes vous gagnez 8 heures de musique
et ça c'est plutôt cool on vient la
recharger également sans fil donc si
vous avez une base de recharge
QI sans fil ça va très bien fonctionner
et bien évidemment ces écouteurs sont
disponibles vous vous en douterez si je
vous en parle bien évidemment vous
pouvez venir les acheter 149 euros ces
tarifs auxquels vous allez pouvoir venir
les trouver alors c'est plus cher que ce
qu'on avait parce que 99 € sur les Iran
et bien on prend 50 balles de plus au
niveau des hirs tout irto R2 peut-être
tout pour rester vraiment dans le
branding de la marque nothing
l'inflation est passée par là
l'évolution aussi au niveau du produit
est passé par là on a pris 50 euros
c'est quand même assez conséquent quand
on passe de 99 euros à 149 euros mais
néanmoins vu ce qu'on a dedans on reste
dans les prix du marché donc il y a rien
de déconnant aujourd'hui donc mon retour
est-ce qu'il faut venir acheter c'est
irto alors si vous avez des Erwan qui
fonctionnent encore bien ou vous avez
des écouteurs de bonne qualité je vous
conseille pas de venir acheter des
hirtoo ne pas venir acheter des
écouteurs pour venir acheter des
écouteurs ne pas venir surconsommer
garder vos écouteurs tant qu'il vous
conviennent et qu'ils font très bien
l'affaire si maintenant vous avez besoin
de renouveler vos écouteurs ou si vous
n'avez pas d'écouteur est-ce que les
hirtoues sont intéressants alors lire
tout ils sont intéressants dans cette
gamme de prix à 149 balles je veux pas
enfoncer des portes ouvertes mais vous
en avez pour votre argent ou plus vous
allez mettre et plus vous allez monter
en qualité et plus vous avez descendre
et forcément vous en donnerez un peu
moins pour votre argent néanmoins il y a
plein de produits aux alentours de 150
balles 129 balles sans 50 balles vous
voyez un peu dans cette dans cette
espèce de grande gamme de tarifs ici et
bien je trouve que eux ils se tirent un
peu leur épingle du jeu sur plusieurs
points déjà sur le design quand même
extrêmement cool le design c'est
important mais pour les écouteurs ce qui
est le plus important effectivement
c'est la qualité audio vous avez une
très bonne qualité sonore dans cette
gamme de prix c'est pas la très bonne
qualité sonore d'écouteurs à 250 balles
c'est une bonne qualité sonore je trouve
que ça manque un poil de brillance qu'on
peut venir récupérer tout doucement via
l'application ici j'adore le fait de
pouvoir venir totalement personnaliser
les commandes tactiles ça c'est très
bien à droite comme à gauche donc on
peut vraiment faire ce qu'on veut ici le
confort est top il tient très bien en
place il y a un peu de médium à mon
homme la vie il y aurait peut-être eu un
truc à venir retravailler ici mais une
fois de plus à 149 €, on va pas lui
demander la lune et pour moi le job est
fait ici donc si vous voulez des
écouteurs très cool qui raconte une
jolie histoire qui en plus sont assez
atypiques avec une marque qui est très
très dit et que tout le monde ne connaît
pas encore aujourd'hui et bien vous
pouvez aller sur les here tout de
Nothing d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse
je vous mets un lien quelque part en bas
dans la description personnellement je
suis assez convaincu je les aime bien et
puis une fois de plus j'aime bien
l'univers de marque nothing alors bien
évidemment je vous l'ai dit il y a eu
les yerwan il y a les Hirt là il y a les
hirstick il y a le nothing phone one à
voir quel sera le prochain produit que
nous proposera nos signes que ce sera
encore d'autres écouteurs ce qui serait
quand même relativement bizarre est-ce
que ça sera un nothing phone tout c'est
complètement possible tout en sachant
que pour une marque et bien ça demande
beaucoup de travail et beaucoup
d'investissements en recherche à
développement même si ils ont déjà dit
que le prochain nothing phone tout
arriverait avec un processeur de
Qualcomm j'imagine hein ça m'agonne 8 GN
2 on verra ça dans les temps à venir on
en reparlera donc pensez bien évidemment
à venir vous abonner c'est pas déjà le
cas et si vous êtes déjà abonné pensez à
venir actionner la cloche pour être
notifié dès qu'une prochaine vidéo
arrivera voilà on reparlera très bientôt
de nos signes de tech et plein de
produits tech très cool donc bien
évidemment je vous embrasse donnez vous
très bientôt ça ça me plaît bien c'est
chouette voilà des bisous à bientôt Ciao